die große energiekrise und jetzt ist
klar dass es schon bald teuer werden
könnte wohl ab oktober könnten
gaslieferanten die gestiegenen preise
über eine umlage an die verbraucher
weitergeben wirtschaftsminister habeck
geht von mehreren hundert euro jährlich
pro haushalt aus
die energiekonzerne wollen uns noch mehr
aus der tasche ziehen und das wohl schon
ab oktober
der staat macht es möglich eine geplante
gas umlage kostet die verbraucher ab
oktober hunderte euros zusätzlich zu den
ohnehin schon ordentlich gestiegenen
gaspreisen die opfer dieser umlage alle
die mit gas heizen sprich und die hälfte
aller deutschen haushalte
wir rechnen damit dass es zwischen 1,5
bis 5 cent pro kilowattstunde sein wird
und dann muss man ein bisschen rechnen
wenn der durchschnittliche verbrauch bei
20.000 kilowattstunden liegt landet man
in einem mittleren 100 euro bereich
hintergrund da russland nur noch wenig
gas lieferte müssen die deutschen
gasimporteure
umdenken das gas wird nun über
alternative quellen bezogen und die
sündteurer die extra kosten die so
entstehen sollen die gasimporteure jetzt
an die gas kunden weitergeben dürfen
ohne mitsprache von wo und wie das gas
zu ihnen in die heizung kommt unklar
wieviel ende august wird der staat erst
bekannt geben wie hoch die umlage für
die gasheizung ab oktober sein wird die
verbraucherzentrale rät daher zu sparen
wäre das irgendwie kann ich schauen dass
man wirklich im sommer jetzt im sommer
sich darum kümmert dass man im winter
dann auch wirklich richtig heizt und
lüftet also ja vielleicht smarte
thermostate jetzt einen bauern zu gucken
passen die dichtungen fenstern und türen
noch und sind die heizkörper auch nicht
verdeckt steht da nichts vor also dass
man wirklich so kleine maßnahmen nach
unternimmt um wenigstens zehn fünfzehn
zu sparen
die dauer der umlage ist angesetzt bis
ende 2024
das geld ist wohl nicht gleich im
oktober fällig aber vermutlich kurz
danach um diesen schritt rechtlich
festzuzurren wird per minister
verordnung der paragraph 26 des energie
sicherungs gesetzes in kraft treten
demnach dürfen die gasimporteure die
differenz zwischen den energiekosten und
der extra kosten für die beschaffung des
gases direkt auf die kunden umlegen
heißt unterm strich gas wird in diesem
winter gleich zwei mal teurer
[Musik]